the optimal nutritional strategy  immediately after a race will always  involve taking onboard a fast digesting  protein source like whey protein and  fast digesting carbohydrates to refuel  the muscle rego rapid recovery plus is a  very advanced recovery drink it includes  whey protein which has a fast digestion  which provides amino acids to the  muscles very quickly after exercise it  has a fast digesting source of  carbohydrates  it also has glutamine in which is a fuel  for the immune system and the gut it  contains leucine which stimulates  protein synthesis in the muscle finally  has electrolytes and minerals as well to  replace those who have been lost in this  way